chuckle I failed to understand a task
that was given to me I take ownership
that I didn't ask the right questions
but extreme ownership applies to my boss
too and she didn't make sure that I
understood it correctly or is that a
poor excuse Oh so optimally in the world
of extreme ownership everybody takes
ownership and there are and I talked
about this with when Dave Burke was on
yes is that the its interlocking fields
of fires so the various people that are
trying to find solutions they overlap
and and problems get solved from two
different directions so the problems get
flanked when this is happening but we
can't guarantee always that everybody
takes ownership and we can't guarantee
that but that doesn't mean that we point
our fingers at someone say you need to
take ownership because Oz as we know
when you do that people get defensive
and then they start blaming you so we
avoid that what we do is we take
ownership so what happens here in this
situation here's the possible outcomes
right if if you go to your boss and you
say to her you know you didn't make sure
I understood right you go cast that
blame there's a there's a decent chance
that G's is where you actually did you
actually need to pay attention that's
not on me and if you don't understand
you need to ask questions so nothing she
doesn't change anything mm-hmm
she hasn't changed anything and you by
the way you've created a little bit of
an antagonistic relationship here
because you're pointing the finger so
that doesn't really help
[Music]
now here's another possible outcome you
know you go and you say hey look I
failed to make sure that I understood
this task
do you mind next time if I give you a
quick read back of what I think the task
is to make sure that I understand it but
so I'm taking full ownership like this
is on me I need to do this and now what
you're more likely to get in this
situation is you know the boss
you know of course absolutely you know
what next time let me make sure I give
you more detailed explanation so that
you have a better understanding that's
on me and all of a sudden we've got this
problem getting solved from two
directions now there's also a chance
that when you say hey when you when you
say something you know hey let me let me
um little nation let me do it read back
with you you might say all that and she
goes yeah cool
you should do that whatever pay more
attention in which case right so she's
not taking any ownership she's like yeah
you should have which is the big theorem
people always have in their head though
when when I say something's my fault
people go yeah it is and now they go
wait a second it's not supposed to work
like that yes it is because when you
take ownership of the problem and I go
you know what I should have asked you
questions she goes yeah you should have
and you exactly that's what I just said
and now you ask questions and now you
make sure you fully understand the task
and now the problem solved hmm so yeah I
think when you ask that question you had
the suspicion once what does he say is
that a poor excuse so you have this
suspicion that was that you were maybe
perhaps unfortunately making a little
bit of an excuse but you're correct it
is a poor excuse take ownership pay in
an ideal world
they'll P person above you in the chain
of command takes ownership as well but
you can't you can't force them to take
ownership yeah so solve the problem take
ownership and get it solved I mean kind
of when you think of it do you and maybe
a follow-up question hmm maybe when you
think about it when you have the
expectation reasonable or not the
expectation that other people have to
take ownership to isn't that essentially
negating your whole extreme ownership
yes whether it negates it or not I don't
know your hope is look the hope is when
I tell you start taking ownership other
people start taking ownership as well
but I can't necessarily control that
alright I can't force them to take
ownership yeah you know I can I can say
hey that's your part of the project you
should have done it they go okay well
whatever I don't think so right
there's a me forcing ownership on you
doesn't really work what I should do is
take ownership what I hope is when I
take ownership of your part of the
project you go
hey jock oh you know what that's
actually something that's actually my
department let me let me take that yeah
that's something I should be running
I go okay cool great so you just took
ownership yes but if you don't take
ownership Roger that I got it and I'm
running really yeah and the genuineness
where this is this was a question like
that kind of you guys we get asked a lot
like well you know when you know it it
would a lot of times be about the other
person taking ownership oh oh where you
all right which is crazy but yeah you
you kind of have that hope you actually
do have that hope yes you're sure but
the actual like expectation that you
know we're like an expectation is there
that can't be let down yeah and I can't
be mad at you right when you don't take
ownership look oh I guess I can't be mad
at you but it doesn't help right yeah
you know if if you were supposed to
write a script for a for a freaking
advertisement that we were gonna do for
whatever sure I'm trying to think of
something cool if we're gonna do an
advertisement and you were supposed to
write a script and then we show up and
you didn't do it and I'm like you know
what hey let me we'll come back tomorrow
I'll go home and write a script yeah and
you're like you what I would like you to
say is know hey you know what jockle
it's actually I'm supposed to write the
script for this whatever I'll do it and
I go okay cool but if you don't do that
you okay cool gonna at the script um I
have to say okay got it finally do some
work now what do I learn I learned that
you're really not in the game and now
I'm probably gonna start looking for
someone else write scripts yeah which
isn't you which is but actually give me
some good ideas yeah that genuineness
though right with yourself yes that's
like if I was just really if I'm just
doing it cuz I'm if I'm just doing it to
get EKKO to do it and I really don't
want to take ownership of it well no
it's not what we're talking about let's
gonna jam you a big test gonna jam me a
big tough acting it's not just mad
it's kind of a step backwards really
like as far as problem-solving within
the team kind of thing but you're yeah
you're gonna be mad and resentful it's
like man no one's like no one's doing
their work no one's taking
responsibility no one's right and you're
essentially in the same boat but just
one in one step behind
you're kind of like the problem is the
opposite yeah I mean you can take this
out to the nth degree as well where I
start taking ownership of so many tasks
that I can't handle them all right
detector you can do that right and then
then you go well you know what we're not
doing this over here why aren't we
getting that done cuz I don't have the
capacity because here's what I'm doing
I'm doing these other 19 things so that
20th thing it's not happening now if you
want to take ownership of it and make it
happen cool you got my support but if
not it's not happening yeah and that's
okay yeah it's almost like when you kind
of visualize it mentally it's like
there's like levels and the extreme
ownership is always on the top so
certain developments can happen you can
take extreme ownership and then like
make certain moves and it'll jam it up
even more just because of the moves you
made not because you took extreme
ownership or took responsibility it's
because the some moves that you made in
proud solving problems which is all
natural but at the end of the day it is
on you like you have to take response
you have to truly say I'm gonna take
ownership yeah and believe it so that
again that genuineness to be like this
is my responsibility genuinely yes it's
yes it's easy to be like the good
example is when someone says well you
know one of my subordinates made a
mistake and of course I of course I get
it yes no I get it but really it was
their fault yeah you know that's where
it doesn't work